you know if we had cable we'd have like
60 channels we have plenty of channels
we have seven hey
there are starving kids in africa with
no channels come on it don't cost much
i'm not paying for television television
is free always was always will be
so cheap
if you want cable pay for it yourself or
better yet try to turn that thing off
and go read a book
read a book
i'm currently this is mtv news fda
commissioner david kessler says just
when do we get mtv
since i got cable
what do you mean you got cable i called
up the cable company and i said hello
i'd like cable and they put in cable i'm
not paying for that keep your shirt on i
paid for it is that so yeah with money i
save from my job
well okay
so do we getting those movie channels
dad i'm trying to watch the news
[Music]
the hell is this
tv's asked me for some kind of code yeah
that's the parental control lock so how
do i take it off you don't this is my
cable that i bought with my money you
got to be kidding me here's an idea how
about you go read a book
oh this isn't over little man
shot
here just for you
what is it
read it you do remember how to read
don't you
a bill really
room and board buddy 50 a month for food
the way you eat i should have gone 50 a
week
laundry services your poor mother has to
touch your underwear
[Music]
what's the ten dollars a month pima
charge oh p-i-m-a that's a pain in my
ass tax
my way of getting compensated for you
taking years off my life
[Music]
well look at that
there's movies on my tv
[Music]
get out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let my feet